how did you get a screenwriting agent
right after college was it I went to the
University of Texas and they used to do
this thing called The Hollywood showcase
where they would take an hour's worth of
student films and they would show it out
here in LA at the DGA theater and they
would invite alumni alumni alumni of the
University just to come and see the
short film just to see like what are the
kids doing back at school and so the
year I graduated I had written I'd
written a short film that played and I
had written and directed another one
side too including a puppet short that
ended up becoming the inspiration for
the happy time earners but so I was you
know living in Austin I was delivering
pizza I was gonna move to Chicago and do
second city and then go to New York
because you know I grew up thinking like
LA like Hollywood like Stella
what am I going to sell out and and so
they picked two of my short films to
play at this thing and I graduated like
on Saturday and a couple days later like
I came to LA just to go to the screening
just cuz I'd never been LA before and I
just graduated I was like I'll go to the
Hollywood Walk of Fame I'll go to the
beach and so I go to the screening and
there was an agent at the screening who
just happened to go to my college and he
was just there to see the shorts and he
liked my short film so much that he
walked up to me at the reception
afterwards and said hey I loved your
short film have you written any features
before cuz I'm a literary agent I
represent writers and I said well I
wrote one for class like I took a
screenwriting class and he's like oh
we'll send it to me I'd love to read it
and I was like sure so I got his card
and I went back to Austin and I mailed
it to him
this is Beck back in the day were you
mailed people things and I just kept
living pizza saving up money to move to
Chicago and then a couple months later
he called me and he just said hey we've
read your script and we love it we want
to sign you and represent you as a
writer but you have to move to Los
Angeles you can't move to Chicago
because we want to
be able to send you to meetings and I
was like okay so I was like out
delivering pizza and I went back and I
was like I'm out I'm moving Hollywood
and just from this short these short
films that I had done that got someone's
attention and you know and I know if the
story is ridiculous and then I was 22
years old and I was plucked from
obscurity but also part of the story is
you know I had these short films that
somebody saw and when he came to me and
said what else do you have I was able to
say well I have this script that I wrote
you know when I gave it to him
and he read that he liked it and so you
know I have a lot of friends who make
short films or you know who as a calling
card which is an amazing calling card is
a short film to get people's attention
and I always tell them like you have to
be prepared for if someone's cheat your
short foeman likes it and then they say
what else do you have what do you have
any features like do you have something
you have to be able to say yes like here
is the other thing because I have a lot
of friends who have this short that
they've worked really hard on and
they'll go play a festival or something
and then they'll meet an agent or a
producer and then the agent will say
what else do you have and they're like
well no I've got some ideas like if
stuff I want to try to start working on
but nothing right now like you can't do
that you have to have something ready to
go that's my piece of advice when going
back to when you were delivering pizzas
did you actually get the call while you
were on a run like you know so this is
actually a really funny story so I was I
graduated and I was living in Austin and
I was I was moving out of my apartment
because for I was going to spend six
months living with a friend of mine in
her spare bedroom saving up money over
the summer and into just like I graduate
in May when you graduate and then I was
gonna move in January so I had like
seven months where I was just gonna
deliver a pizza and make money and so I
had to move out of my apartment so I
moved everything out of my apartment
except my answering machine the only
thing that was still in my apartment
because this is before I don't even got
a cell phone yet
this 2001 so I had an answering machine
and when I gave that agent a business
card by the way still my agent
so my last day here we are 16 years
later when I gave him a mic card in Los
Angeles the only number that was on it
was my apartment in Austin because then
I have a cell phone so the only way he
had of contacting me was to call my
apartment so I hadn't heard from him for
like 2 or 3 months or whatever I was
like oh I guess he never got mice
character didn't read my script so the
only thing left in my apartment was my
answering machine so I went and I moved
to everything over the new place and
then I had to go back clean and then
take the answering machine away so I go
back to clean and there's a red light
blinking on the answering machine and I
was like oh I have a message and a beep
there's like hey Todd it's a Steven from
the counter agency really read your
script give me a call had I had I gotten
to my apartment like an hour earlier and
unplug the machine I just never would
have gotten my call from him who knows
if he would have tried to track me down
by some other means but um but but that
message was waiting for me and the only
thing left in my apartment was that
answering machine so knocking on wood
that was really lucky but I then got a
cell phone and I stayed in Austin for
like three months delivering pizza
because I still need to save up money to
move to LA cuz just because then I had
an agent doesn't mean I was like rich or
something I still needed to afford to
move to LA so delivering pizzas saving
up money I bought a cell phone and I
gave it to my agent my agent my new cell
phone number and he took my scripts that
I wrote for class and he get he he gave
me some notes on it and I did a new
draft and then he sent it around town as
a spec script and he showed it to a
bunch of producers and like I didn't
know what that meant and so I'm I'm out
on a delivery in Austin
and my phone rings and it's my Hollywood
agent and he's like Todd hey we went out
with your script and we just set it up
at Paramount at the it was kelsey
Grammer's company at the time Graham net
and I was like oh oh cool like I don't
know what that means what does that mean
and he's like well it's $10,000 option
plus you're gonna get writers guild
minimum of 27,000 to do the guaranteed
rewrite and I was just like I'm sorry
what what he's like yes so it's a
guaranteed $37,000 and I was just like I
was like that's more money than I've
ever even heard of imagining because I'm
making like $7 an hour at this piece of
place so I was it was like a dream I was
like I couldn't believe it and they went
back to the double Dave's pizza where I
worked and I walked in and I was like
I'm out I quit I'm Hollywood now but
then I'm a nice guy so actually finished
my shift oh that's good I think I even
finished work one more shift but then I
and then but then I quit and then I
moved to LA but that being said I did
there and learn the harsh realities of
like I then it's not like everything I
wrote got sold or I got jobs that easy
like I thought that's how it works
because my first script out the gate
like I got optioned and got a rewrite so
I was just like oh every script I ever
write now it's gonna get optioned and
set up but no it took it took a while
for it to happen again the second time I
hit lightning in a bottle that first
time and I moved out to LA thinking like
I'm a wunderkind I'm an awesome young
hotshot 22 year old and then the harsh
realities of being a working writer
actually set in and I got hard how soon
after that
oh pretty soon pretty soon like I wrote
another script you know I moved out I
wrote another script and I'm like cool
let's show this one I'm sure I'm gonna
set this one up and no one cared pure
Lena now what else I was like oh and
then years I mean years went by before I
actually set up another one of my own
scripts because you know I learned very
quickly that when you want to be a
working writer it's not like you write
scripts and then
sell them to people most jobs you're
ever gonna work are you writing scripts
for other people based on their ideas or
pre-existing material so it's not like
people are looking for original scripts
as much it is hey we need a writer to
rewrite that draft of the Ninja Turtles
movie or you know we bought the IP for
some 80s cartoon and we need a writer to
write a script for it and so I very
quickly realized like oh I actually have
to work really hard now to go to
meetings and meet producers and try to
get an assignment that's what it's
called
- in order to get paid it's so like
right stuff and for years that's all I
did I mean today it's at this day that's
my primary source of income is I just do
assignment work which is a hard job like
you spend half your time trying to get
the next assignment and then the little
free time you do have you try to work on
an original script that you hopefully
can sell to someone someday
you